imaginez une ancienne décharge
transformée en ferme
c'est le pari un peu fou mais réussie de
l'association le vivant et la ville en
2014 elle a créé le premier
démonstrateur d'agriculture urbaine de
france c'est un démonstrateur parce que
sa vocation d'être dupliqué sur d'autres
sites délaissé la particularité c'est
que tout est hors sol par nature même
des sols qui sont qui sont pollués ou
contraint toutes les technologies
agricoles sont développés au dessus du
sol
là vous ou situé dans la zone de
production et ont produit des fraises
des framboises et tomates cerises qu'on
va ensuite en circuit court et c'est
l'intérêt de faire des fermes en ville
c'est de pouvoir alimenter l'ensemble
des populations qui vivent aujourd'hui
la plupart du temps en ville une
ancienne friche de près de 4 hectares
devenu un jardin d'éden
l'hiver les équipes préparent les beaux
jours ils viennent d'aménager la culture
des fraises se fit là il vient protéger
d un segment protéger du vent il a pas
mal de fonctions thermique mais on a
décidé de réinstaller c'est la première
fois qu'on le fasse cette année un
tunnel plastique dessous pour gagner en
précocité et pour
commencer plus tôt dans la saison
avantage du hors sol l'eau qui n'est pas
absorbée par les plantes et récupérer
pour être réinjectés une économie non
négligeable pour cette denrée précieuse
les particuliers peuvent aussi jouer les
apprentis maraîchers depuis 2015 la
ferme en ville s'est lancée dans la
location de jardin si vous souhaitez
louer un jardin vous disposez d'un
morceau de cabanes ou d'une malle en
fonction de l'option vous prenez et
ensuite 50 mètres carrés vous avez deux
bacs et demi cela correspond à peu près
à 25 mètres carrés de culture avec un
cours de jardinage par mois une
irrigation automatique qui vous
j'enlève l'astreinte de l'arrosage ce
qui est en soi un confort qui est pas du
tout négligeable
vous cultivez hors sol du coup vous êtes
en hauteur vous avez moins de vous
baisser et c'est une manière de
sensibiliser le grand public
depuis deux saisons l'intérêt des
citadins pour ce dispositif se manifeste
de plus en plus aujourd'hui 50 % des
abonnés vient de saint germain en laye
boulogne même paris on pense que
l'avenir de l'agriculture urbaine
ce sera probablement une filière
multifonctionnel associer des métiers
qui sont complémentaires
à voir à la fois des métiers de service
comme typiquement la location de jardin
et des métiers de production comme ce
qu'on voit ici autour de nous une zone
qui est dédiée à la production
professionnelle pour ensuite vendre
cette production pour pouvoir fournir
les urnes en circuit court
chaque année la ferme en ville crée des
emplois saisonniers pour s'occuper des
cultures elles produites en moyenne 12 à
13 tonnes de fruits et légumes par an
elle espère arriver à 18 tonnes dans
quelques années